let me tell you what the future you need
to be worried about is not the next 20
years but the next 20 minutes what are
you going to be doing what are you going
to be doing to be effective I mean
you'll never be perfect good Lord we're
all human basket cases I mean that's how
we're all wired one of the things that I
can't stand is people you know all these
celebrities and people that want to be
like them the truth is you have to be
the best you you can be he's the former
co CEO of prime America
he's a sought-after speaker motivator
and business officer he currently serves
on the board of directors for America
and LegalShield
he's John Addison and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success rule number
one is my personal favorite and I'd love
to know which one you guys like the best
and as always guys if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below put
quotes around it as well so other people
can be inspired also when you write it
down you're much more likely to lock it
into yourself as well
enjoy
your habits determine what direction
you're going your success in life your
results in life are in direct proportion
to your habits what do not what you say
you're going to do but what are you
going to do you've got to develop
successful habits and I believe that
starts with being a daily goal setter
and a daily goal hitter that you get a
you know too many people spend their
whole life they say they're dreaming but
they're really just pipe dreams they're
thinking about what they want to be
doing in 20 years and what their plans
are way out in the future let me tell
you what the future you need to be
worried about is not the next 20 years
but the next 20 minutes what are you
going to be doing what are you going to
be doing to be effective when you get up
every day know your priorities life will
overwhelm you stuff will overwhelm you
the with all the information we have now
whether it's your phone where sometimes
I think we have smart phones and stupid
people I mean it is so easy to get
consumed by a bunch of stuff that is not
going to get you where you want to get
to say every day I will do today what
others don't so I will have tomorrow
what others won't you've got to choose
to be effective know what your
priorities are know what your must dues
are don't let your phone don't let your
you know your tablet don't let the TV
don't let your friends knock you off
what are the most important things to
get done today Sir Winston Churchill
didn't have an inbox he had an action
this day box and so things didn't get
into that box that he wasn't going to
deal with that day so may as John Wooden
said make today your masterpiece get up
today and get it done finish the day
half the day and go change your life
you don't look life is short you know
we're already you know well into the
first month of 2017 now I'm reaching an
age where I do oh my god I remember what
you know when I was launching the year
2000 it seems like yesterday well you
know that 17 years ago time flies
it moves on all of us the one thing that
is constant is change the world moves on
time moves now we can choose whether or
not we move with it but time moves and
you're not going to get a do-over
this isn't a dress rehearsal for the
second time you live on this earth you
know I mean I'm not one of the people
that's you know big in reincarnation I
guess if you're one of those eight maybe
you think there's a do-over
but I don't believe we got to do over on
this earth it's our shot here it is our
time and it moves by on you quickly you
need to find what you are truly
passionate about in life most people
spend their whole life just enduring
their work they hate it they can't stand
it they don't want to they don't want to
you know they live for Friday and then
they dread Monday well you know I'm here
to tell you that's no way to go through
life find what you're passionate about
find something you enjoy find something
that makes you excited to get up every
day and then pursue that sometimes it's
a certain you know you got to go through
go through a lot of process to get where
you want to you can't you know but start
by volunteering with something you love
and then meet the right people ask the
right questions and try to get yourself
to a place where how you earn your
income is something that you would do
even if there was
money attached to it I'm telling you
living a life where you're passionate
where you're excited and you get after
it
that's a great way to go through life
being most of us chase money until the
time runs out we'll find a way to get
paid maybe even if it's not as much as
you were making doing something else but
it's something you love is something you
believe in and something you want to do
you know I believe with everything in me
it honestly is your ability to drive
yourself and your team to a level of
excellence that is what's going to
determine your future I was watching the
other day right after we got back from
the RDP meetings and I was sitting in my
study and there was on HBO a special
about Vince Lombardi that's been on a
number of times and you know in that it
was Bart Starr talking about the first
million you know you gotta remember the
panel this was a guy that had been
locked out of jobs locked out of jobs I
mean he was like in his late 40s by the
time he got his first head coaching job
and you know was and it was in Green Bay
okay yeah I mean it was like in the
middle of I mean it's like my god what
would the New York Giants it was in
Green Bay and they've been terrible and
his first meeting with the team what
he's Bart Starr said he always remember
the exact words he said he said we will
relentlessly pursue perfection we won't
catch it but in our quest we will catch
excellence and see in life I believe
that's what separates the people that go
do something great is that they
relentlessly pursue perfection they beat
themselves up every day when they're not
perfect when they don't do the right
thing and stuff but by being relentless
at that you mean you'll never be perfect
good Lord we're all human basket cases I
mean that's how we're all wired I mean
we all got more snakes in the Attic
then I mean trust me I know I do okay
but at the end of the day when you
relentlessly pursue perfection
you'll catch excellence the one thing
that is absolutely certain is change
happens things change
look you can either embrace change or
you can get run over by change you can
either shape change or stand there
screaming kicking and complaining about
things changing the world changes time
moves on and you have to adapt and be a
person you know like I said you can
either you can either you can either be
a force for change or you can be a
victim of change you've got an embrace
change and get after it you know
everybody wants to change the world but
nobody wants to change themselves and
you've got to look at yourself every day
and say am i adapting am i moving
forward am i a part of the future or am
I just sitting and telling stories about
the past look the world will be I don't
know what the world is going to look
like in 10 years I wish I did
I'd make some investment to make a lot
of money but the reality is I know one
thing for sure it'll look different than
it does today so every day work on
yourself get better you're a human
becoming not a human being
work on yourself get better and go be a
force for change not a victim of change
let me tell you I'm going to tell you
key it's not easy to win if it sounds
easy it sleazy in life
you got to pay a price you got to fight
everyday you got to get up and make a
decision that you're going to play wide
open
oh I'll leave it all on the field every
day is a battle you know Napoleon Hill
said in Think and Grow Rich thought or
things Earl Nightingale and the
strangest secret said you become what
you think that is the truth that's the
way life is so my question for you is
who you control your thoughts who
controls your thinking's who do you give
the keys to your brain to turn on the
news we have mastered you know
technology and information is great but
I believe with every great thing there's
an equal bad thing to it now you can put
garbage into your brain 24/7 you turn on
the news there's a person talking
telling you bad crap bad craps going
across the bottom bad crap strolls down
the side
now I'm not saying I'm not saying don't
you know watch the news and just be an
ignoramus or anything you know but what
I'm telling you you've got to be careful
what you allow to get here you know in
in data processing there's a say in
garbage in garbage out with the brain
it's garbage in garbage stains you've
got to be careful you know I'm up I'm a
huge gardener I love to garden I've got
my wife and I have a have a home in
North Georgia I've got 50 acres when I
get home you know next week
you know I'm planting all my tomatoes
and all this stuff I have a huge huge
garden I love I love to garden but one
of the things you learn about gardening
is it is easier to grow weeds than it is
to grow vegetables we just show up it's
amazing and it's very much like the
brain you've got a life if you want to
grow positive things in your life you've
got to wean your brain all the time
and if you let a winky bean to weed
early and often if you let it get tall
you'll pull the weed out the root will
snap off and then it's right back with
your brain it's the same way you have to
fight to be positive that's what you
read who you talk to
who you hang out with see in life
there's the power of association but I
can important thing many of you need to
learn is the power of disassociation
every one of you has people in your life
that if you ask them how you're doing
how they're doing you wish you could
stuff the words back in your mouth
because they will tell you negative
people share much more frequently than
positive people they will spend two
hours just putting their garbage and you
know you just crush you down you've got
to be around positive people positive
thinking positive things in your brain
but that's not a bunch of rah rah rah hi
that is a fact you're in the people
attraction business and so I tell people
all the time John you know give me a key
what could I do
smile walk fast be going somewhere I
live in airports I'm a three million
mile or old Delta okay I live in an
airport and I am amazed at the number of
people that come up to me and go Chuck
or you know they don't know my name
they'll just go you seem so happy
something good must have happened yeah I
woke up see you know one of the things
I've learned over time is that the best
you'll ever be if you're trying to be
someone else is a pale imitation you
know most people spend their whole life
look at it you know this I want to be
like this person I want to be like that
person what a you know one of the things
that I can't stand is people you know
all these celebrities and people that
want to be like them
the truth is you have to be the best you
you can be there's only one you I mean
there's not another one on the face of
the planet now you need to learn from
other people from some people you need
to learn what not to do from something a
lot of people you need to learn what to
do but as you study people as you look
at successful people study their trades
study their behavior study what they do
and then take the best and leave
the rest you have to create an authentic
you now does that mean you don't need to
learn from other people no but you've
got a step back and go well okay this
person is super outgoing in full and I'm
not wired that way maybe I'm quieter we
are never going to be like them but
learn from them take the best and then
when you look at some other person
that's got a great skill set that maybe
doesn't line up with your skill set but
take and learn things that you can put
to work in your life but factor all of
that together by understanding who you
authentically are find what you're good
at all of us have a list of things that
we're good at
but the treat is we spend way too much
more time working on what we're bad at
trying to get better at it well I'm
telling you the thing that you're
naturally bad at and you can work all
day long seven days a week on it and the
best you'll ever be at that is mediocre
somebody is naturally good at what
you're bad at but I guarantee you you
have natural skills that were just
boring you a part of your DNA that
you're good at without even trying and
then other people are terrible at it I
mean I've always been able to speak in
front of people it's never bothered me
for a lot of people it mortifies them
it's never been a real problem and so
what I was able to do is find a way that
there was something I knew that I was
good at that I could show up without any
notes and do better than most people and
then work like crazy at it spend my time
focused on what I'm good at
see I believe each of us if we found our
natural inclinations and then we focused
on what we're good at
you're going to be the best you you can
be
I believe great teams are made up of a
bunch of individuals who find a way to
mesh together in a way that accentuates
each person's positive for the good of
the group so being the best authentic
you you can be work on yourself focus on
yourself understand your strengths and
weaknesses and find ways to put yourself
in a place where your strengths are
magnified most of us that come from just
normal backgrounds we don't see
ourselves doing abnormal things the
world is full of people who were born on
3rd and think they hit a triple and
they've got all this confidence all this
stuff for most of us it's not that way
we don't think we're wired or programmed
to do something great I'm telling you
that thought is nothing but a fear
nothing but a doubt it's what holds you
in place you got to work hard on
understanding you have within you the
power to change the power to do
something great and those fears are
going to crop up particularly in the
middle of the night when you wake up and
you're scared to death about what to do
they're going to crop up and they're
going to hold you in place quite often
if you trying something different they
crop up in the middle of your dreams
when you're asleep at night those fears
and doubts creep in understand they're
not real they are things in your head
that have been programmed into you by
your past life wrestle with those fears
you'll never conquer them but control
them and go out and live the life you
deserve choose to win control your
thinking and go in big I do not want to
go to college but with my mom it was not
an option I was going to college
but I wanted to quit I was looking for a
reason to quit and so the first class
I'm sitting there dr. Miller
political science 101 and get there the
first day enough where do you if you
really don't think you belong where do
you see it back road far back as you can
get I was almost out the door sitting in
the back of the room and at the end of
the death you got us in I was from the
country okay
you'd get to UGA then and most of the
students in your class came from
Buckhead which is the very nice area of
Atlanta and went to the right schools
and they had all this college prep stuff
and I didn't have any of that and so
this is in the 70s when the preppy look
was in the girls were the big-booty hair
and bows in it everything and so this
girl with this big poofy hair and a bow
in it and stuff was sitting in front of
me and it's in the class she goes dr.
Miller when we receive a syllabus today
and I'm like how I had no idea what a
syllabus was if she'd have said a
schedule of when we were taking the
tests I'd have gone yeah I need one of
those okay so I leave class and go back
to my dorm Milledge hall and go down the
end of the pay phone you know no cell
phones and stuff then and I call my dad
and I go dad I hate this place I hate
these people I hate everything about it
I hate it I hate it hated I want to come
home and he said son we've already paid
your tuition for this quarter just go
through Christmas and then come home and
we'll talk about it and so I went okay
dad that's fair enough so we go back few
weeks later we have our first exam now
don't let the accent so yeah I'm pretty
good in school and I was always good
school that's why mom baby jota and i
and if i you know like a history or
class political science class if I read
something I remember things and so first
exam I get my test back and I made a 98
and I look down in front of me and that
little smart girl
what a syllabus was made of 46 okay I
bet she didn't wind up CEO of a
multi-billion financial services company
but now but the reason I tell the story
is what if my dad had said son get your
butt home I'm sick of hearing from you
and I went back to mobile chemical
company and was the funny guy working on
the assembly line where would my life
have gone
what would I wouldn't be speaking in
front of a big group I wouldn't be
wealthy I would none of those things
would have happened in my life if I
don't let her make me quit see that
light it moves on small decisions when
you keep going when your friend quits
when you keep moving here's reality new
people I'm going to tell you the reality
your friends don't want you to succeed
they want to tell you that you're doing
some crazy crap that you'll get over
they if you succeed you put pressure on
them if you win it makes them
uncomfortable they want to be able to
say told you so
you've got to make a decision that
you're going to prove all the doubters
wrong that you're going to stay up keep
forward I know now I'm reaching an a
just turned 59 the other day and I'm
reaching an age where you know you do
look back on things a little bit and you
know as I look at the world today I'm
going to be completely honest with you
sometimes I'm afraid we're losing our
toughness okay the ability to demand
results I believe there are two things
in business in sports or whatever it is
there's results and there's bull okay I
mean most people spend all their time
talking making excuses talking about why
they didn't get it done winners get
results there is a scoreboard in life
there is a thing called making it happen
I've been at business points in my
career you know in the in 2008 when the
economy collapsed my partner Rick
Williams and I knew we had to get our
business separated from Citigroup
we knew we had to make it happen not
getting it done was not an option we had
to make it happen and it was hard and we
didn't know what to do every day but
when a door would close we'd find a
window you've got to win you got a take
responsibility for where you're at
you've got even sometimes even if it's
not your fault
and then you've got to go get after when
you're playing the golf I used to play
golf a lot you hit the ball off the tee
into the rough you can't just go you
know I'm in it to be out there in the
middle of the fairway you got to play
the ball where it lies and go get
results so that requires toughness it
requires discipline and it requires
getting after it on a daily basis so
that's my challenge to you whatever
challenge your problem or where you're
at in your career
go out get tough and get results weather
vanes typically our politicians wear
whatever way the winds blow and whatever
the mood of the moment is whatever the
polls say they spend that direction
leaders are lighthouses there's a
consistency to their strength too you
know lighthouses are only needed when
the weather stormy and it's beautiful
they're just a pretty building but when
the seas are storming and it's dark and
rainy and foggy that's when you need a
lighthouse a leader has to be abroad so
one of the consistency that when the
storms whether it's in business what the
economy whatever is happening to the
organization that you're over that
you're a human alka-seltzer you calm the
organization I mean I've worked for
people that were closing quote leaders
who you know would bring a bucket of gas
to a fire and make it you know just turn
it into a blaze by how they reacted to
it great leaders are comers great
leaders are people that when maybe
everything is hectic and chaotic but
when people see them hear from them
they're calmer I believe a peaceful mind
generates power
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Pablo Bernal
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are in a profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do I'd also love
to know what did you love most about
this video which clip resonated the most
of you and what lesson are you going to
immediately apply somehow to your life
or your business please leave it down
the comments below and I'm super Cheers
to figure it out finally I want to give
a quick shout out to Joseph DeVito
Joseph thank you so much for picking up
a copy of my book your one word I really
really really appreciate it and I hope
you're enjoying the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
season
you got to take control of your life not
waiting for the government not waiting
for a corporation you taking charge of
your economy you know a lot of people
call it the gig economy the share
economy all of those kind of things what
I really think it is is you controlling
the means to your income instead of
letting the means to your income control
you it's you taking control of your life
it's you becoming the captain of your
ship and charting your course and
deciding when you want to work how you
want to work but see that takes
education that takes working on yourself
the key to you is you and that means
you've got to improve you've got to
learn you've got to get better
you've got to hone your skills and your
craft every day and that's where I
believe success comes in a lot of people
adapt to pressure differently Peyton
Manning to just retire one of the
hydrogen sleep one time break koko d had
was pressure is a privilege I mean you
know I'm sure he's going to miss him now
okay
pressure is a privilege you know you
might not enjoy enjoy the journey it
goes by very fast once you all of us all
grows
what you focus on grows you focus on
problems problems multiply if you focus
on opportunities opportunities will
multiply you have to choose what you're
going to spend your time though see
every day is you're either getting
better or worse you don't stay the same
in life people don't stay the same
during they're getting better or their
work you're not a human being you're a
human becoming okay every day you are
changing your life and you are every day
becoming your crevice domina ho not what
you say you're thinking about that would
you tell other people you're doing
you are becoming what you're thinking
Napoleon Hill said Oh are these random
electrum you'll synapses between nerve
it is oh please
what are you allowing to be in your
brain what are you focusing on what is
meeting your time old solution fluency
you